pet food oh God that's far away isn't it
[Music]
well well well Color Me surprised when I
discover the night of the consumers a
game that you weirdly like got an update
after three years I don't know what the
update is I just know that there's an
update and there's apparently new
content new secrets to discover and
there's going to be more updates in the
future so we can all relive the
nightmare that was customer service or
is and oddly enough this did come at an
opportune time didn't this didn't this
release like right at the peak of covet
did I talk about that man that is weird
anyway all right that's right
yes thank you all right let's try this
again what's with the piss bottles
toilet paper and piss bottles
what's this topical
oh hi hey what's up wham wham wham wham
wham wham hello
hi
well you don't know that since you knew
around here I'll cut you some slack my
name is the manager good name I'm not
too busy on days like this so you can
have a nice easy shift to help you get
settled in but remember I've got a
reputation of uphold you don't have me
looking like a fool in front of the
other man is this with you
the store is the best in town and I
would like to keep that word
[Music]
I will be hearing about it all right
enough of that
okay go find Jimmy that was probably
important information because I don't
remember how to play okay whatever Wham
in
ah
what
that
is new
isn't it lixian is that new
good whatever your answer was I was
paying attention I always do
love me hello where'd they go what
happened out there are you okay
hello huh I can't take this anymore I
don't get paid enough for this
the rude customers
the endless amounts of sick
steins
I've reached my Breaking Point the seat
is up to you now
there's still a lot of empty shelves out
there
they need to be stuck before we close
you don't know how to upset the manager
you take this it's all the notes I made
while working here these tips saved me
time and time again
press escape to view the note at any
time whatever that means is good luck to
hell with this place I'm out of here
okay
do I have to clean that up
all right throw box it stuns them
oh God no Lexi and obscure that penis
obscure it immediately don't get caught
staff rooms
beware the baby
beware the baby why must I beware the
baby
I don't recall it being a baby
God oh God is the game of foot
oh God it's the game of what
drinks I don't remember where anything
is
I don't remember where anything is okay
sweets drinks got it
[Music]
oh
oh God
[Music]
not that way
oh frick oh Fricks oh God what do I do I
bought a phone it didn't come with a
bloody charge cable HR we'll hear about
this hurry oh wow I don't know what you
want
I don't remember uh video games
electrical
there you go
all right I gotta get this Halloween up
here
[Music]
oh hi I need didn't I just help you
didn't I just help you what coffee cups
coffee cups
oh oh no not like this no please I have
a family I don't but imagine if I did
all right there you go man hey
congratulations
I would like to look at your selection
of furniture please okay
all right furniture
there you go
oh God
okay
[Music]
pet food oh God that's far away isn't it
okay yo where the screws at I don't know
I don't know where was DIY DIY was
somewhere I remember there being DIY
DIY
DIY all the way over here
there you go don't talk to me ever
because
it's midsectional
why are you doing jumping jacks right
there okay don't
[Music]
get off Remo
am I okay I'm not okay am I okay I'm
okay am I okay
listen I just got done with an email I
know where the drinks are I I just had
the drinks yeah
I just stocked the drinks yep sure did
well
[Music]
oh thank
you
okay well I missed lost my baby
I got oh all right there you go ma'am
[Music]
oh God
dude how did you lose your baby again
what is wrong with you
okay all right oh
where do you I fly
oh no
no no
you know I'd almost forgotten about the
nightmare I don't know what they added
though this seems just like the same
horrible experience that for some reason
I mastered before
I gotta remember to hide in the staff
wait
what is that
laughs
don't trust manager what
what
okay there's the kitchen but hold on a
second
what what
was that about
Jesus
[Music]
okay maybe that was the only one with
something in it but that was weird
that was new maybe maybe I discovered
that before
maybe I did maybe I didn't I don't know
this game is always a travesty a
beautiful travesty
[Music]
there's one right outside the door and I
don't know why go for it
[Music]
DIY
uh it's right across the way this is
great this is great fantastic don't
don't okay
okay
[Music]
is this how the Hand Works before
because oh my God
oh my God the food yeah the layout is
atrocious I don't have anything to do
with that man I really well I'm in
trouble
okay
I'm just gonna yeah take that oh
wait no no no okay I need that box don't
get up get out do anything
[Music]
just gotta stay clean for the ladies I
understand
I understand
I don't know what that would be for a
health and beauty okay
you got it what yeah you uh deserve that
so close
[Music]
try me
Try Me
Maybe I could rest in here for a little
bit longer
hi no
oh
this is not worth it
dog soup you're stuck wait why do you
guys say that to me like that
oh God
[Music]
video games
uh-huh
[Music]
well not today very busy
okay video game here we go
ma'am do not come over here
[Music]
good that was three
good stuff
good music
great music dude I have a quota
sorry very busy drinks are over here I
just gotta be smart about things
the problem is I'm not very smart to
begin with oh yeah this is it
why why are you being a pain
that was five
did I do it did I get everything that I
needed to get because holy crap that was
awful can I just wait out the rest of
the day please
I did so much
I literally did so much
Aldi all right
I don't even know where the uh there's
another box over there I'm in trouble
oh man why screws
[Music]
DIY electrical is over here
Pharmacy Great why is this game also one
of the most effective uh horror games
well no not today all right
out here
oh boy
thank you why not the baby one wait but
but this is not fair but I was almost
done
hold on ma'am ma'am your baby's right
here
[Music]
I don't even know if I need to do
anymore oh frick not today I just want
to get this done
oh I'm screwed
screwed I'm screwed
okay you're not talking to me what's
happening a Halloween ride of course yes
yes Halloween yes Halloween Halloween is
right was right uh here
that is a very stressful noise
hate I'm just waiting it out because if
I lose this round then I probably have
to do this whole day over again and I'm
not about that after this I'm gonna look
up what is new because I'm not gonna
play through this entire game again just
to get to the something tiny
I better find something
oh boy
am I done
why what did I do wrong
what do you mean but I did what you were
asked all right I'm gonna find out
what's new
interest
okay so it's just the ending of night
one that's been updated so I was close
but
I didn't get it oh what's this then
how do you explain this
I don't get what I need to do I don't
know what you want from me
[Music]
holy new garms what's a garms
right there
oh great good guys
um
[Music]
I missed I missed what spit tartar sauce
all over my new cardigan I am cleaning
uh oh
I think oh man
I don't know uh cleaning where'd
cleaning go
where'd cleaning go
cleaning's gone oh
it was right there
oh boy uh well listen buddy hey uh pal
uh listen
Mr
oh my God why did you come down that
aisle Jesus cleaning wow look cleaning
who'da thought it's right here well
that's a problem
oh God come on
little bit of the bubbly eh
oh don't you worry um I'm gonna bury you
in bubbly what was the
oh
my God it thinks I went to the wrong
place that's not what it was I just so
happened to be going past an island
can I please just can I please just
oh let me live let me live
new set of dining chairs okay
where'd my cleaning box goes gone
[Music]
bad food
your insides are hungry come with me
can you please leave me be while I stock
the cleaning cleaning cleaning home
cleaning there's no cleaning what
oh
that was nice and efficient I'm
definitely winning
[Music]
well
I should never walk around without at
least one box in my hand right
oh boxes two damaged okay
all right you got it
thanks
so I can't throw this anymore but
there's no cleaning section unless
there's another oh wait maybe it's like
home cleaning versus actual
cleaning is cleaning different
[Music]
okay great
sugar is good for you I'm sure it is pal
I'm sure it is oh my
God oh
man oh boy oh boy oh boy
I have an idea because I'm not gonna
make it no no no no no no
I'm gonna wait it out here
this is it
can wait it out I can wait him out he'll
never find me he can't fire me if I'm in
here
what the frick oh my God oh my God
why am i stuff what
nope nope nah okay so it seems like
there's going to be more endings it's uh
more updates to this which is surprising
and you know I'm I'm
into that like seeing if there is
anything out there of like amazing
importance about this uh feel free to
add to the video right here and give
credit where credit is to whoever you
ruthlessly steal it from just remember
to give credit and then everything's
okay just like consumers of the store
you can steal whatever you want as long
as you give credit
uh go ahead go ahead
I'm waiting
no
[Music]
foreign
all right so whatever that was I bet it
was worth it uh Alexian will be going
away for a while
um don't know why but he committed some
horrible crimes being arrested put in
jail forever justly deserve so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below and if there is an update
to this yes I'll give it another go
because why not always good to relive
the nightmare that is customer service
thank you and as always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
foreign
[Music]